hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime outbrower and today we are diving
right back into the increasingly dark
and tragic developments in the black
clover manga
megicula one of the strongest devils
ever
the evil goddess has found a way to
manifest fully into this world
regardless of what happens to the
cliffhoth and we just witnessed what
might be one of the most tragic
deaths in black clover it's like romeo
and juliet but with
devil magic so let's get into it if you
enjoyed the black lore content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going you know what to do just leave
a like and comment
it only takes a second but it helps with
the youtube algorithm
and of course if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
but you haven't subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and
instagram at anime uproar finally this
video will of course contain black
clover manga spoilers we are talking
about the manga so please proceed with
caution
you have been warned the latest chapter
starts off with a shocked noel wondering
how megikula was able to manifest
into this world when only the first gate
of the underworld has opened
as one of the strongest highest ranked
devils megikula should be on one of the
lower floors possibly even on the bottom
floor
and yet here she is seemingly in the
flesh
a lot of people were confused when
makikula suddenly showed up in the
previous chapter
but thankfully this chapter provided a
lot of the information that we
desperately needed megikula explains
that yes she can manifest
through the gate of the underworld like
the other devils but she also has a
special power called
curse warding magic evil goddesses curse
this is an extremely complex and
time-consuming magic spell
and mkikula has been working on it for a
very very long
time but now it seems that she finally
has found a way to bring this
spell to completion megikula confirms
that the first step to activating the
spell
was the death of aussieer silva in my
previous black clover video
i talked about not being sure whether
aussie a counts as a sacrifice
or whether all the sacrifices had to be
powerful female mages who are still
alive
right now makikula clarifies that as
long as her curse kills a powerful
female mage
it doesn't matter when the mage died so
yes assie does
count as the first sacrifice mkikula's
manifestation into this world
seems to be a step-by-step process and
she seems to have been planning this for
many
many years when asea died all the way
like 17 years ago
she was able to half manifest within
vanica's body
this explains why we sometimes saw
megikula taking over half of anika's
body
and even making manika's body do things
that veronica didn't necessarily
want to do the second step in this evil
master plan was to curse
loropachika which also happened quite a
while ago since loro hasn't
died yet mkikula wasn't able to make any
further progress with her manifestation
spell
but now with vanica about to die after
her defeat at the hands of noel
megikula was able to manifest in an
imperfect state
as a sort of parasite upon vanica's body
in order for magikala to manifest fully
in her perfect form
both fannika and loro pachika will have
to die and become the second
and third sacrifices so essentially
megikula has a way of entering this
world through the back door
because of her overpowered curse magic
she can enter through the cliff off like
all the other devils but she can also
enter without the cliff
off if these three sacrifices are made
this means that just stopping the
cliffhoth ritual won't be enough to stop
megicula our heroes have to stop the
cliff off ritual
and prevent magikula from killing loro
pachika and
speaking of loro saving her from akikula
is going to be anything but
easy that's because makikula managed to
use the curse affecting loro
to somehow turn her into a devil a devil
who now seems to be under megicula's
complete control
in fact devil loro now possesses a new
type of magic
demon water magic and this new magic
certainly does not have any issues with
offensive attacks
in fact this demon water magic looks
absolutely
deadly as soon as the magic activates a
massive
water hydra with many heads appears
around loropichika
and the hydra advances on gaia noel can
tell right away that this is extremely
bad
and she tries to stop megikula before
she can do any more damage to loro
but megikula possesses a spell called
curse warding magic
decaying whirl which is able to negate
noelle's magic and stop her attack
in its tracks megikula is clearly way
stronger than vanica was
and she says that the only person who's
been able to counter her curses thus far
has been the queen of briars
charlotte this is a clear indication
that charlotte is about to become
relevant in the fight once again
and since i like charlotte as a
character i'm glad that she has unique
powers that will likely come in handy
during this
spade kingdom showdown this is not the
last we've seen of charlotte
and that's actually awesome because i
want to see her stay on the front lines
and eventually have an epic reunion with
yami
oh and it's around this time that real
remembers that hey
maybe i should stop standing around and
actually do something during this fight
taking inspiration from noel's norse
mythology-based magic
real creates a massive picture magic
spell called
twilight of valhalla but as cool as this
spell
is and as amazing as it's definitely
going to look in the anime
unfortunately mcgill's cursed warding
magic is able to counter it
and at the same time that this main
battle against magikala is happening
gaia is using his true lightning magic
to make his way around that demon hydra
in a desperate attempt to reach
loropechica since
loro couldn't use offensive magic in the
past gaia put all of his effort
into becoming the strongest attack mage
in the heart
kingdom his goal was to battle all of
the enemies of the kingdom
in his queen's place and he is just so
loyal and so dedicated to laurel
and he is determined to save her from
this nightmare
but then just as gaia manages to reach
loro's body the devil loro extends her
demonic
arm and pierces straight through gaia's
torso delivering what seems like a
fatal wound man tabata really enjoys
having characters stab
each other clean through the torso
doesn't he does anyone have a counter
for how many times a character got
stabbed cleaned through in black clover
if you do let me know down in the
comments but it has to be like a dozen
and
just when it seems like things can't get
any worse
noelle's spirit dive runs out and she
and undine
are separated as megikula declares that
the good guys have lost
this tragic and dark chapter ends
and man this was really really harsh and
really dark
poor gaia makikula seems so overpowered
in this moment and she's only gonna get
stronger
not only is she able to easily negate
incredibly strong spells from noel and
rill
but she is also able to control the
insanely strong devil loro
at the same time i think that vernica
will very likely die
and be sacrificed during this fight so
we can expect megicula to get
even stronger once that second step is
completed
and the second sacrifice has been made
after that
loro will be the only one left and if
loro dies then it's really game over
i think that noel will certainly use her
ultimate magic against mkikula
and charlotte will use her true briar
magic as well
but will that be enough judging by
everything that we've seen so far
i don't think that this will be enough
to defeat megicula especially not after
vanukkah becomes the second sacrifice
and this will likely make magikala much
stronger i think that noel
charlotte and real will certainly put up
a valiant fight but with mkikula being
so overpowered and the devil loro
also there ultimately i think that
asta's anti-magic will be required to
stop megicula i've been saying for a
while now that i want to see an asta and
noel team up
so maybe that is going to be how
megicula ultimately goes down
let me know how you guys think this
fight is going to end down in the
comments below
also we need to talk about how tragic
lauro's fate
has been after everything that she's
been through with the curse and with
getting kidnapped and possessed
she now may have just killed gaia her
most
loyal companion against her will this
girl has suffered
so much and even if she survives this
ordeal
if gaia dies laura will never be able to
forgive herself
yes she was being controlled by megicula
but lora will definitely still blame
herself and this is so
tragic not only is gaia a faithful
servant to loro and not only has he
dedicated his entire life
to serving her but there have been some
hints that loro and gaia have romantic
feelings for each other you better
believe that a lot of people ship
them so this turn of events is going to
be absolutely devastating
both for the two people involved and for
everyone who ships them
if loro and gaia really were in love and
if gaia really
is going to die here then this would
become such a tragic
romeo and juliet type story and honestly
i don't think i'm ready for something
that deep
in black clover what do you guys think
is gaia about to
die at the hands of loro herself or is
he going to make it
to be honest based on what we've seen so
far in the story it could go either way
also do you think that loro is going to
end up dying during this arc
or will our heroes find a way to save
her from akikoula
and finally how are they going to defeat
megikal in the end
let me know down below if you enjoyed
this black clover video and you want to
see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime out pro or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications you
really have to go through the trouble of
subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting
that option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he's an
absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
dr cortman the toasted chee the spike
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis big buddhist cody hebert
and monkey d
quilly and of course i want to thank our
pro hero to your patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh the red
on hell cruise anatoly kazatsuki very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokamian water joy and garcia ted
noted fat boy games corey mcgowan metal
mama deadly saint and soul ray slice and
dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patreon exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you